pour sa première visite à la frontière
sud des états unis depuis qu'il a quitté
la maison blanche donald trump a
transformé l'événement en véritable
meeting politique avec une mise en scène
parfaitement calculé d'abord cette table
ronde de donald trump entouré du
gouverneur du texas et des autorités
chargées de la protection de la
frontière une frontière qu'ils estiment
avoir été dégradé depuis son départ de
la maison blanche la frontière n'a
jamais été pire qu'en ce moment dans
toute l'histoire des états unis voilà
les propos de donald trump le l'ancien
président qui a défendu son bilan
défendu la construction du mur on sait
le chantier a été arrêté depuis que joe
biden est arrivé à la maison blanche
c'est donc l'administration démocrate
qui en a pris pour son grade dans les
propos de noël tron d'écouter tout ce
qu'ils avaient à faire c'était de ne
rien toucher le mur était en train
d'être scellé
là c'était les zones à finir on était en
train de ramener les équipements parce
qu'on ne voulait pas le laisser au
mexique
on ne voulait pas laisser les grues
camions et tracteurs au mexique on était
en train de tout ramener en deux mois on
our et terminé et il voulait arrêter
tout ce que ben laden avait à faire
c'était d'aller à la plage s'ils
n'avaient simplement rien fait on aurait
aujourd'hui la frontière la plus solide
qu'on ait jamais eu
c'était en train de s'améliorer tout
s'arrangeait les trafiquants d'êtres
humains les avait stoppé et maintenant
ils reviennent à un point qu'il n'aurait
jamais imaginé nous on avait presque
tout arrêter beaucoup de messages à
destination de la maison blanche de la
part de donald trump joe biden est en
train de détruire notre pays a notamment
déclaré l'ancien président républicain
il faut dire que la crise migratoire est
inquiétante aux états unis avec des
chiffres records d'arrivée de
clandestins illégaux sur le territoire
américain 180 mille personnes ont été
arrêtées rien que sur le mois de mai
mais du côté de la maison blanche on ne
veut pas évoquer le terme de crise
migratoire alors certes
kamala harris s'est rendu en amérique
centrale il y a quelques semaines en
expliquant aux populations locales ne
venait pas mais elle a été très
critiqués on sait parce qu'elle ne s'est
pas rendu sur place à la frontière et
finalement elle y est allée alors
c'était vendredi dernier et pour donald
trump et ses soutiens évidemment elle
est allée parce que donald trump avait
annoncé qu'il s'y rendrait
c'était donc une façon pour elle de lui
coupe
et l'herbe sous le pied mais ça n'a pas
empêché quelques moqueries de la part de
l'ancien président qui estime que la
vice présidente ne s'est pas rendu à
l'endroit où il ya réellement des
problèmes à la frontière contrairement à
ce que lui estime être le bon endroit on
l'a vu lors de son discours au pied du
mur qui sépare donc la frontière entre
les etats-unis et le mexique
ce mur d'ailleurs dont le chantier a été
arrêté bien certains souhaiteraient le
reprendre c'est le cas par exemple du
gouverneur du texas donc greg abbott un
gouverneur républicain qui est à
l'origine de l'invitation adressée à
donald trump pour se rendre sur place et
bien ce gouverneur voudrait poursuivre
la construction de ce mur en utilisant
par exemple un financement de l'état du
texas ou des dons privés
ce sera assez compliqué d'un point de
vue légal puisque la gestion des
frontières américaines est du ressort
des autorités fédérales et non pas d'un
simple et a en tout cas donald trump
avec cette visite a une nouvelle fois
poursuivi ses meetings politiques en
quelque sorte puisqu'il était dans
l'ohio il ya déjà quelques jours et lors
de cette visite à la frontière il n'a
pas été question que de la crise
migratoire mais d'un certain nombre de
sujets notre homme qui est revenu sur le
laboratoire chinois de one ou encore sur
la dernière élection présidentielle
il poursuit sa rhétorique selon laquelle
il est le véritable vainqueur de cette
élection
voilà pour donald trump qui il faut le
noter était entouré d'un certain nombre
d'élus républicains pour cette visite
la preuve que l'ancien président a
toujours beaucoup d' influence ici aux
etats unis